I'm sorry, but we have to do a song at the beginning? Thank you.
Come on, Stacie.
Okay, here's two dollars.
Thanks.
I'll be right back.
What are you doing in the kitchen?
Time to see songs with Lottie.
The Pulse of the show where Lottie comes out and sings a silly song.
Silly songs today.
Corruption.
We can't do it.
What?
Rock.
It's gonna be now!
It's gonna be.
I'm not Mr. Lunt.
Here it goes again.
I am extremely hungry.
Pikachu.
It's okay.
It's just one of my workers.
You're petting her the right way.
You are.
At first you weren't.
That's why she didn't like.
Don't bite him.
It's okay.
You on our Pokemon yet?
Yes.
All again?
Oh boy.
I missed all yours.
The Lugia one.
My Lugia wasn't.
Your Lugia wasn't.
They have those ones.
I hide in you.
Jessie.
Identification.
What's the name of those?
I don't know.
What is your name?
Miss Lugia.
Miss Lugia?